eight Penn State fraternity members are
due in court today in connection with
the death of a student pledge 19
year-old Timothy Piazza died in February
after a fall a grand jury report says
the fall came during a fraternity hazing
ritual involving heavy drinking he hurt
his head and ruptured his spleen
prosecutors say that the fraternity
members waited about 12 hours before
they called for an ambulance the members
are also accused of then trying to cover
up the incident
Jericka Duncan is outside the fraternity
house in State College Pennsylvania
Jericho good morning good morning those
18 members of the Beta Theta Pi are
facing charges ranging from hazing to
aggravated assault now the National
Organization the National fraternity
said it has disbanded the group and said
it does not tolerate alcohol abuse or
hazing it's a sentiment that is shared
by the university president how could a
group of people who have committed
themselves to each other let something
like that happen Penn State University
President Eric Barron describes the
grand jury report on the incident
surrounding the death of Timothy Piazza
as sickening according to the report
Piazza arrived at the frat house on
February 2nd there he and 13 other
pledges took part in the gauntlet a sort
of alcohol obstacle course where the
pledges consumed approximately four to
five alcoholic beverages varying from
beer wine and liquor all within a two
minute time span an hour later the
report says Piazza fell down a flight of
stairs surveillance video inside the
frat house apparently shows him carried
up by four bethe brothers his body
appears limp his eyes closed and his
demeanor unconscious Piazza Falls
several more times throughout the night
hitting his head in some instances while
on the floor frat brothers step over his
body by 10 a.m. the next morning to fret
brothers found Piazza on the basement
floor they say he was cold to the touch
and his skin appeared pale but no one
called 911 until 42 minutes later
there's a friend who's unconscious
neither nerve uses coal Cheviot starting
that noise okay how old is he fears
right thing yes I guess arching years
old
the next day Tim Piazza was dead his
father called this a preventable and
senseless tragedy again it's did not
have to happen no parent should have to
deal with this
a grand jury determined Piazza died as a
direct result of extremely reckless
conduct of members of the beta
fraternity the report also says the
investigation shows an active attempt to
conceal and or destroy evidence by some
frat members Tom Klein represents the
Piazza family the lack of humanity the
lack of caring the lack of dignity of
the young men who did so much harm here
is unthinkable and it doesn't end with
just the criminal case since the release
of that grand jury report the university
has now launched its own investigation
and the university president tells me it
could very well lead to expulsion
Charlie Jericka thanks